bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
de blaise pascal et j'annonce
immédiatement que cette vidéo sera la
première d'une série que je consacrerai
à pascal parce que ce n'est pas le genre
d'auteurs dont on peut résumer la pensée
en une vidéo
c'est vrai pour tous les auteurs bien
sûr mais ça l'est d'autant plus pour
pascal dont pascal est un philosophe
français du xviie siècle
mais ce n'était pas seulement un
philosophe c'était aussi un grand homme
de science un mathématicien de génie
on lui doit l'invention de la première
machine à calculer la pascaline qu'il a
créé à 19 ans et dès l'âge de 12 ans
parce qu'elle a été capable de
reconstituer la 32e proposition
d'euclide alors même que son père lui
avait formellement interdit d'étudier la
géométrie
comme quoi son père savait comment s'y
prendre pour éveiller la curiosité de
son fils et c'est à l'âge de 16 ans que
pascal a publié son premier traité de
géométrie donc pascal grand homme de
science mais aussi théologien sur la fin
de sa vie et c'est ce double intérêt
pour la science et pour la religion qui
en fait un personnage atypique est
remarquable religion à laquelle pascal
s'est convertie suite à son expérience
mystique ce qu'on appelle sa nuit de feu
qui l'a raconté dans un texte qu'on
appelle maintenant le mémorial et c'est
de l'art en partie que vient sa
réflexion sur le rapport entre la raison
et la foi
rapports entre la raison et la foi qui
va nous intéresser aujourd'hui et comme
porte d'entrée à cette réflexion j'ai
choisi de partir de cette célèbre
citation le coeur a ses raisons que la
raison ignore
parce que oui avant d'être une phrase
qu'on se fait tatouer sur l'avant bras
il s'agit d'une citation de pascal alors
comme je sais que certains sont très
pointilleux
je précise que la citation exacte c'est
le coeur a ses raisons que la raison ne
connaît point mais ça ne change
absolument rien au sens de la phrase 1
on va pas pinailler sur ce genre de
détails
en revanche il ya une question qui
mérite d'être posée
c'est celle de l'interprétation que l'on
donne à cette citation
c'est la question de la signification de
cette phrase qui est très souvent mal
comprise
alors pourquoi je dis que cette phrase
est mal comprise parce que la plupart du
temps quand on entend cette phrase on
pense spontanément qu'elle fait
référence à l'amour elle fait référence
au sentiment amoureux c'est à dire à ce
qui se produit en nous lorsqu'on tombe
amoureux et c'est vrai que l'amour c'est
quelque chose d'irrationnel c'est
quelque chose qui échappe totalement au
contrôle de la raison l'amour est
irrationnelle par essence
on pourrait même dire déraisonnable par
essence l'amour nous pousse à faire les
choses que nous ne ferions pas si nous
n'étions pas amoureux on dit d'ailleurs
qu'on est fou amoureux quand ce
sentiment prend une forme
particulièrement intense est
l'expression même tombé amoureux montre
bien que l'amour peut être comparée à
une chute à une chute de la raison à une
chute du contrôle et ça évidemment ça
nous fait tout de suite penser à ce que
disaient les stoïciens sur la nécessité
pour la raison de garder le contrôle sur
les sentiments et les émotions donc
l'amour est irrationnelle par essence et
ça va même encore plus loin parce que
quand on aime quelqu'un on ne comprend
pas vraiment ce qui nous arrive on ne
comprend pas vraiment ce qui se passe en
nous ça peut prendre la forme d'une
expérience quasi mystique pour le coup
mystique au sens étymologique du terme
c'est-à-dire de mystérieux et c'est vrai
que l'amour est un mystère parce qu'il
échappe à toute tentative de rational
a sion n'échappe à toute logique
intellectuelle et ce n'est pas pour rien
que l'amour a nourri l'art et la
littérature depuis des milliers d'années
dès l'antiquité dans les tragédies
grecques ce qui était illustré c'était
ce conflit fatale ce conflit mortelle
entre l'amour et le devoir
entre la passion et la raison et on a vu
des empires s'effondrer on a vu des
guerres déclenchées au nom de l'amour et
contre toute raison
et au 19e siècle l'amour a donné lieu
aux mouvements du romantisme c'est à
dire l'exaltation du sentiment la
recherche de l'absolu et pour les
romantiques le sentiment amoureux
c'était une expérience de l'absolu et
l'absolu qui nous des saisies de notre
souveraineté sur nous mêmes parce que
l'amour est un sentiment qui nous
envahissent c'est quelque chose de
transcendant qui fait qu'on se sent
portée par une force une force
mystérieuse à laquelle on s'abandonne
donc c'est en ce sens que l'amour est
irrationnel il est irrationnel car c'est
une force qui écrase la raison et qui
lui fait perdre sa couronne
lorsque l'on aime la raison ne règne
plus la raison est destitué de son rôle
de gouvernante une preuve du caractère
irrationnel de l'amour c'est qu'on peut
très bien aimé quelqu'un qui nous fait
du mal
la raison voudrait que notre amour se
portent uniquement envers les personnes
qui nous font du bien
les personnes qui nous rendent heureuses
les personnes qui nous élève
or on voit bien que dans les faits ça
marche pas tout le temps comme ça et il
n'est pas rare qu'un nos amis nous
racontent qu'ils n'arrivent pas à
quitter quelqu'un qui pourtant lui fait
du mal donc lorsqu'on est extérieur à
cette situation bien entendu ça nous
paraît aberrant ça nous paraît absurde
parce qu'on ne comprend pas le principe
qui conduit à accepter volontairement
une souffrance que l'on pourrait éviter
et on comprend encore moins l'idée
d'aimer celui qui est à la source de
notre souffrance mais ça nous paraît
aberrant quand on n'est pas soi même
habité par ce sentiment amoureux
c'est tout simplement une question de
point de vue un point de vue extérieur
par définition il n'est pas impliqué il
n'est pas engagée sentimentalement comme
peut l'être la personne amoureuse est
d'ailleurs la personne amoureux se rend
parfaitement compte du caractère
illogique de sa situation
personne ne trouve logique personne ne
trouve cohérent d'aimer quelqu'un qui
nous fait du mal mais c'est simplement
le constat d'un sentiment que l'on peut
pas repousser dont on ne peut pas
s'extraire
ça prend la forme d'une véritable
fatalité donc la première raison pour
laquelle on peut dire que l'amour est
quelque chose d'irrationnel
c'est parce que l'amour fait plier la
raison c'est parce que l'amour haute à
la raison son pouvoir de décision mais
il ya une deuxième raison pour laquelle
on peut dire que l'amour est quelque
chose d'irrationnel
c'est que l'amour ne résulte jamais d'un
examen rationnel de la personne qu'on
aime
qu'est ce que ça veut dire mais ça veut
dire que l'amour ce n'est pas le
résultat d'une addition des qualités de
l'autre l'amour n'est pas le résultat
d'une évaluation des qualités de l'autre
parce que si c'était effectivement le
cas
ça voudrait dire qu'on pourrait décider
de tomber amoureux décident et tombe
amoureux ou décidé de ne plus être
amoureux c'est comme si on pouvait faire
la liste des qualités de l'autre qualité
selon nos propres critères bien sûr
qualités pour nous et qu'à l'issue de
cette liste
après avoir coché toutes les cases on
pouvait en arriver à la conclusion que
ça y est on est amoureux
mais ça marche pas comme ça ça marche
pas comme ça ça n'a jamais marché comme
ça et même si la télé réalité et les
applications de rencontre on veut nous
faire croire qu'on pouvait tomber
amoureux d'un profil avec la liste des
qualités que l'on va cochet ça n'existe
pas on ne tombe pas amoureux d'un profil
on ne tombe pas amoureux d'une liste de
qualité
on tombe amoureux d'un regard tombe
amoureux d'un sourire d'une voix on
tombe amoureux parce qu'on aura vécu un
tremblement de terre parce que des
secousses sismiques auront fait naître
une éruption volcanique en nous
c'est ça l'amour l'amour n'est pas le
résultat d'une série d'opérations
algorithmique donc tous les slogans des
applications qui vous promettent de
rencontrer l'amour faut bien comprendre
qu'il y a publicité mensongère
on peut vous promettre de rencontrer la
personne qui possède les qualités que
vous recherchez je ne peux pas vous
promettre de trouver l'amour
vous ne savez pas comment vous allez
trouver l'amour peut-être que vous le
rencontrerez chez une personne qui par
ailleurs koch les critères alors là
c'est c'est l'apothéose
mais peut-être que vous aller le
rencontrer chez une personne qui coche
aucun des critères
on n'aime pas quelqu'un pour ses
qualités on aime quelqu'un pour ce qu'il
fait vibrer ans et ce n'est pas pas
que la personne a des qualités que nous
l'aimons c'est parce que nous l'aimons
que nous lui trouvons des qualités c'est
parce que nous l'aimons que ces qualités
nous apparaissent on aime d'abord et
ensuite on trouve les qualités qui
viennent justifier notre sentiment c'est
dans ce sens là que ça se passe
regardez ce qui se passe quand vous
décrivez la personne que vous aimez un
de vos amis
cette personne là vous voit plein d'
enthousiasme des étoiles dans les yeux
le sourire aux lèvres en train de parler
de la personne que vous aimez
et donc voulu fait la liste de toutes
les qualités de cette personne et vous
le dit à quel point c'est génial que
cette personne soit comme ci comme ça
qu'elle est telle ou telle qualité qui
pour vous sont des qualités essentielles
on est bien d'accord qu'en faisant cette
description à votre ami votre ami ne va
pas pour autant tomber amoureux de la
personne dont vous lui parlez c'est à
dire que toutes les qualités de la
personne que vous aimez que vous lui
aurez cité ne vont pas créer chez votre
ami un sentiment amoureux pour cette
personne pourquoi parce qu'on tombe
amoureux d'une liste de qualité et votre
ami à qui vous fait l'article de toutes
les qualités de la personne que vous
aimez
à ce moment là tout ce qu'elle voit ce
sont les étoiles dans vos yeux c'est
votre sourire c'est à dire ce sont les
réactions physiologiques qui indique
votre amour c'est ça qu'ils voient votre
ami à ce moment là donc vous bien sûr
que vous essayez de rationaliser votre
amour vous allez chercher à lui trouver
une explication à lui trouver des causes
objectives et dont vous allez citer
toutes les qualités de la personne que
vous aimez comme pour vous rassurer de
ne plus être sous le contrôle de votre
raison comme pour vous rassurer
ne pas être entièrement assujettis à
votre amour mais c'est une illusion
c'est une vision et vous savez
parfaitement vous savez parfaitement
mais quelque chose en vous a besoin de
se dire que si vous êtes dans cet état
amoureux c'est qu'il y a des raisons
rationnelles mais vous savez très bien
que non vous savez très bien que c'est
l'amour qui préside aux qualités que
vous allez reconnaître à la personne que
vous aimez vous savez très bien que
votre amour précède votre raison et que
la raison ne fait que trouver un chemin
pour justifier votre amour donc voilà
pour la deuxième raison qui fait qu'on
peut dire que l'amour est un sentiment
irrationnel
c'est que l'amour ne résulte pas d'un
examen objectif des qualités de l'autre
l'amour ne procède pas d'une évaluation
c'est quelque chose qui excède tout
examen toute analyse et c'est quelque
chose dont la raison aurait bien du mal
à rendre compte
alors maintenant je vais appliquer la
règle d'or en philosophie qui va être de
poser une objection
je vais poser une objection à tout ce
que je viens de dire et pour ça je vais
convoquer schopenhauer parce que
schopenhauer vous dirais que l'amour
c'est en réalité un sentiment très
rationnel pourquoi c'est un sentiment
très rationnel et bien parce que pour
schopenhauer
l'amour c'est d'abord la manifestation
de la volonté de l'espèce de se
reproduire avec le partenaire idéal donc
autrement dit l'amour du point de vue de
schopenhauer
c'est tout simplement l'expression très
rationnelle de la volonté de l'espèce du
point de vue de l'espèce l'amour est
quelque chose de rationnel
parce que c'est ce qui nous fait aller
vers le partenaire avec lequel nous
avons le plus de chances d'avoir une
descendance optimale alors je sais que
certains trouveront ça extrêmement
cynique et désabusé mais on va adopter
ce point de vue et on va voir où ça nous
conduit donc je rappelle la position de
schopenhauer
lorsqu'on aime quelqu'un ça signifie
qu'on reconnaît en lui le géniteur le
plus adapté pour perpétuer l'espèce dans
des conditions optimales
lorsqu'on aime quelqu'un c'est qu'on
entrevoit en lui les meilleures chances
d'optimiser notre descendance d'avoir de
beaux enfants
si on voulait le résumer simplement
alors évidemment c'est inconscient on ne
le formule pas de manière explicite mais
le sentiment amoureux et l'expression de
cette reconnaissance en l'autre du
partenaire idéal donc pour schopenhauer
l'amour ce n'est rien d'autre qu'un
stratagème de la nature pour préserver
nos gènes pour préserver nos gènes et
les propager correctement
donc c'est un point de vue naturaliste
pourrait-on dire et c'est un point de
vue qui n'est pas du tout aberrant du
point de vue de l'évolution des espèces
parce qu'après tout si tous nos affects
ont une fonction physiologique de même
que la peur est un signal pour nous
avertir d'un danger bien pourquoi ne pas
admettre aussi cette idée que l'amour
aussi à une fonction biologique ce pas
du tout aberrant de penser donc du point
de vue de l'espèce du point de vue de la
nature l'amour serait quelque chose de
très rationnel donc ça veut dire qu'on
ne tombe pas amoureux de n'importe qui
on tombe amoureux de la personne avec
laquelle on s'estime compatible
compatibles ou complémentaires ça
revient au même
voilà pourquoi généralement la personne
qu'on aime
elle possède à la fois des qualités qui
nous sont communes
mais elle possède également des qualités
que nous n'avons pas
c'est ce qui me la rend complémentaires
et c'est ce qui donne une image de ce
que platon appelé les androgynes c'est à
dire des êtres qui sont à la fois homme
et femme qui possède un seul corps mais
tous leurs membres sont en double donc
il ya bien cette idée de tronc commun
d'unités et en même temps cette idée de
polarité d'opposition qui crée la
complémentarité
et là qu'est ce qu'on peut répondre à
schopenhauer on peut lui répondre que ok
du point de vue de la nature du point de
vue de l'espèce du point de vue de la
vie l'amour est quelque chose de très
rationnel mais du point de vue de
l'individu
du point de vue de l'individu qui
éprouvent ce sentiment amoureux
cette reconnaissance en l'autre du
partenaire idéal
cette reconnaissance ans l'autre de la
moitié qui nous complète elle se fait de
manière totalement inconsciente elle se
fait en deçà de toute analyse en deçà de
toute réflexion c'est à dire que là
encore reconnaître dans l'autre celui ou
celle qui va nous donner les plus beaux
enfants
ça ne se fait pas à travers une analyse
physiologique
ça ne se fait pas à travers un examen
analytique ça se fait de manière
instinctive et donc cette reconnaissance
de l'autre comme partenaire idéal pour
la reproduction
elle se fait de manière immédiate elle
se fait de manière directe et l'amour
c'est le raccourci qui nous permet
d'arriver directement à la conclusion à
la conclusion que cette personne est la
plus adaptée et la plus compatible pour
assurer notre descendance
parce que le sentiment c'est la voie
d'accès la plus directe à la certitude
donc on pourrait dire que l'amour c'est
ce qui nous fait gagner du temps dans le
travail de recherches et de
reconnaissance de celui qui nous
convient le mieux
c'est une ligne directe sans escale qui
nous permet de savoir qui est fait pour
nous
alors évidemment quand on utilise ce
genre d'expression ça semble présupposés
une sorte d'intention de la nature ça
semble indiquer l'idée d'un plan d'un
plan cosmique ou d'un plan divin peu
importe c'est à dire d'une volonté
surnaturel à la limite peu importe c'est
pas ça qui compte
ce qui compte c'est la manière dont ce
sentiment est reçue c'est la manière
dont il est éprouvée et dont il nous
fait agir
or le fait est qu'il n'ya pas de
sentiments plus puissant que celui qui
nous dit que la personne qu'on aime est
fait pour nous et c'est ce qui fait
l'efficacité de ce sentiment
du point de vue de l'espèce la seule
chose qui compte et qu'on doit retenir
c'est que cette reconnaissance dans
l'autre des qualités qui nous complète
et qui vont nous permettre d'avoir la
meilleure descendance cette
reconnaissance
elle se fait de manière immédiate par le
sentiment amoureux
elle se fait sans passer par le détour
de la raison on le sent c'est pour ça
que ça s'appelle un sentiment et ce
sentiment
c'est en même temps un savoir on le sait
donc on sait que c'est cette personne là
vers laquelle on doit aller évidemment
ce savoir ne peut pas être démontrée il
ne peut pas être justifiée
rationnellement parce que l'amour est au
delà de toute démonstration
l'amour est au delà de toute
argumentation puisqu'il est au delà de
toute raison c'est ça qui fait toute sa
puissance
le fait qu'il s'agisse d'un chemin
direct un chemin dans lequel tout
questionnement devient superflue un
chemin dans lequel toute réflexion n'est
qu'un ralentissement
parce que parfois la réflexion ce n'est
rien d'autre que l'art de compliquer des
choses simples la réflexion s'est
parfois l'art de nier l'évidence
au prix d'efforts et d'une dépense
d'énergie assez considérable
donc cet amour il prend la forme d'un
savoir que l'on peut pas démontrer mais
c'est un savoir au sens où il prend la
forme d'une évidence aussi forte que
celle qui nous dit que de + 2 égale 4
l'amour prend toujours la forme d'une
évidence et qu'est-ce que l'évidence
c'est la reconnaissance immédiate de la
vérité c'est la reconnaissance immédiate
de la vérité que l'on ne peut pas
démontrer autrement que par notre
sentiment d'évidence
c'est en ce sens que le sentiment peut
être le vecteur d'une connaissance
lettre le vecteur d'un savoir c'est un
savoir qui ne s'obtient pas en
parcourant les chemins indirecte de la
raison c'est un savoir immédiat et
saissac pascal appel connaître par le
choeur connaître par le sentiment parce
que sentir la vérité c'est quelque chose
que la raison ne pourra jamais faire
c'est quelque chose face à quoi la
raison est impuissante et dont je disais
tout à l'heure que la citation de pascal
donnais souvent lieu à un malentendu sur
sa signification réelle parce qu'en
réalité dans cette phrase pascal ne fait
pas directement référence au sentiment
amoureux
c'est moi qui ai choisi cet exemple pour
vous faire comprendre ce que signifie
connaître par le coeur parce qu'au
départ pascal voulais décrire le rapport
entre la foi et la raison et il voulait
montrer qu' on ne peut connaître dieu
que par la foi et non par la raison
il voulait montrer qu'il y à des vérités
qui sont par définition inaccessible à
la raison est que dans la plupart des
cas la raison ne fait que confirmer ce
que le coeur savait déjà
alors confirmer ou infirmer
parce qu'il arrive que la raison ait
contre l'évidence du coeur et on en
parlera à la fin de cette vidéo
mais dans son analyse du rapport entre
foi et raison
pascal insiste sur le fait que la raison
ne peut pas tout savoir et que toutes
les vérités de la raison sont d'abord
construite sur les vérités du coeur d'où
d'ailleurs chez pascal l'idée qu'il est
vain de vouloir démontrer
rationnellement l'existence de dieu
de ce point de vue là pascal ses
lentilles des cartes là où descartes
pensé qu'il fallait passer par la raison
pour conférer une légitimité à l'idée de
dieu
pascal pense au contraire que c'est une
entreprise vouée à l'échec
précisément parce que la raison est
incapable de se hisser à cette forme
particulière de connaissance qui est la
connaissance de dieu connaître la vérité
par le coeur ça veut dire que le socle
de toutes nos connaissances rationnelle
c'est le socle des vérités du coeur et
donc pour le montrer pascal passe par
beaucoup d'autres exemples qui n'ont
rien à voir avec le sentiment amoureux
pascal étant un amoureux des
mathématiques ils utilisent souvent des
exemples de géométrie nous savons
intuitivement nous savons par le choeur
que par un point peut passer une
infinité de droite mais ça c'est pas
quelque chose qui peut être démontrée
par la raison c'est pas quelque chose
qui peut faire l'objet d'une
démonstration mathématique sous la forme
d'un alter m c'est une évidence
c'est un postulat est par définition un
postulat est indémontrable tout ce que
nous appelons des postulants c'est ce
que pascal appelle des vérités du coeur
c'est à dire des vérités indémontrable
par la raison mais dont on ne peut pas
douter
et donc il ya une vraie distinction
opérée entre les vérités du coeur qui
sont des vérités immédiate qui ne passe
pas par le prisme de la raison et les
vérité rationnelle qui consiste en un
enchaînement d'opérations intellectuelle
pour parvenir à un résultat
je disais tout à l'heure que la
réflexion c'est parfois l'art de
compliquer des choses simples et l'art
de détourner le regard des évidences et
d'ailleurs la méthode scientifique se
réclament de cette démarche puisque
précisément la démarche scientifique
consiste à aller au delà de nos
impressions sensible au delà de nos
perceptions
effectivement si le savoir scientifique
n'était construit que sur nos
perceptions se savoir serait un peu
bancal parce que parfois nos perceptions
sont trompeuses
nous sommes soumis à des biais
sensorielle nous sommes soumis à des
illusions et donc construire le savoir
scientifique sur la seule base de nos
perceptions ce serait pour le moins
hasardeuse mais sauf que pascal fait
bien la différence entre la perception
et le sentiment le sentiment ce n'est
pas la perception le sentiment ce n'est
pas l'impression
et ça c'est une grande confusion qu'on
fait très souvent lorsque l'on parle
d'intuitions c'est de confondre le
sentiment et l'impression c'est de
confondre le savoir du coeur et le
savoir du corps le corps peut nous
donner de fausses informations
la sensibilité du corps et les
différences de sensibilité des corps
c'est quelque chose qui va nous amener à
avoir des perceptions parfois totalement
différente d'une personne à l'autre
quand vous aurez chaud l'autre aura
froid quand vous verrez du vers l'autre
verra du bleu ça c'est le savoir du
corps et le savoir du corps est propre à
la subjectivité sensorielle il est
propre à la sensibilité personnelle de
chacun mais sauf que les vérités du
coeur dont parle pascal n'ont rien à
voir avec les vérités du corps
précisément parce que le coeur c'est la
représentation de notre discernement
c'est la représentation de notre
clairvoyance pour pascal lecoeur ne se
trompe jamais c'est ce qui pollue le
coeur qui nous fait nous tromper
c'est ce qu'ils parasitent le coeur
c'est ce qui obscurcit le coeur qui nous
conduit à l'erreur
mais le coeur au plus profond de lui il
sait il s'est toujours et de la même
femme
son que pascal a eu besoin de sept nuits
de feu de cette expérience mystique qui
lui a permis littéralement de contempler
dieu bien le coeur parfois a besoin
d'expérience mystique qui vont être
comme une sorte de révélation de
révélations qui va balayer tous les
parasites âge du corps et de la raison
apprendre à écouter le coeur c'est
apprendre à ne pas écouter ceux qui
empêchent le coeur de parler c'est
apprendre à ne pas écouter les bruits de
la raison qui cherchent à s'opposer au
coeur qui cherchent à contredire les
vérités du coeur donc quand la raison au
terme de toutes ces opérations
analytiques intellectuelle parvient aux
mêmes conclusions que le coeur bien
évidemment ça nous fournit alors une
démonstration qui est communicable aux
autres parce qu'une vérité du coeur est
incommunicable elle est indémontrable
donc elle ne peut pas faire office de
connaissances admise voilà pourquoi le
savoir scientifique ne peut pas se
contenter des vérités du coeur
le coeur alors besoin du secours de la
raison pour valider son savoir et pour
lui donner une forme transmissibles
c'est ce qui fait que la raison c'est le
seul terrain sur lequel il est possible
d'exprimer des arguments un argument
émotionnelle par définition n'est pas un
argument
c'est une tentative de faire passer pour
un argument ce qui n'en est pas un mais
lorsque la raison abouti aux mêmes
conclusions que le sentiment alors à ce
moment-là ce savoir devient
universellement acceptable il devient
acceptable il devient transmissibles il
devient démontrable et c'est ce qui fait
que tout le monde va pouvoir s'accorder
dessus
c'est ce qui fait qu'on va pouvoir lui
accorder du crédit et de la solidité
mais ce n'est pas parce que le savoir a
besoin d'être démontré par la raison
pour être transmissible que ça signifie
que le sentiment n'est pas capable de
savoir
comme le dit pascal les principes se
sentent les propositions se conclut
et il est inutile de demander à la
raison ce qu'elle est fondamentalement
incapable de faire c'est-à-dire de
démontrer les principes principe trinket
sens latin c'est ce qui est premier et
par définition la raison ne peut jamais
parvenir à ce qui est premier
puisque la raison elle déduit et on peut
déduire qu'à partir de quelque chose par
exemple on peut déduire la meilleure
stratégie pour parvenir à un objectif si
on a préalablement défini notre objectif
mais l'objectif qu'on aura défini il
peut ne pas être du tout rationnel
il peut même être déraisonnable un
objectif a davantage à voir avec le
désir qu'avec la raison donc ce qui est
rationnel ce n'est pas l'objectif que
l'on vise ce qui est rationnel c'est la
procédure stratégique que l'on va
engager pour atteindre l'objectif c'est
toujours dans cet ordre là d'abord
l'objectif
ensuite les moyens de l'atteindre mais
tout ce que l'on pose comme premier tout
ce que l'on postule ne découle pas de la
raison la raison est structurellement
secondes dans tout ce qu'on entreprend
et ce qui est intéressant c'est que dans
le texte où il parle des vérités du
choeur pascal écrit que c'est en vain
que la raison et c'est de les combattre
c'est en vain que la raison et c'est de
combattre les vérités du coeur ils
savent très intéressant parce que ça
nous montre bien cette idée non
seulement de dualité mais même de
conflit entre la raison et le sentiment
comme si la raison avait pour seul
objectif de contredire le sentiment
comme si la réflexion s'était donné pour
mission de nier les évidences
et ça c'est intéressant parce que ça
nous permet de comprendre aussi à quel
point la raison peut parfois se montrer
tyrannique voire hystériques dans sa
tyrannie à savoir ce besoin de détruire
ce que le coeur nous dit et c'est
d'autant plus intéressant que la raison
elle est toujours orienté vers ce que
l'on voudrait qu'elle démontre quand
vous considérez quelqu'un comme votre
ennemi vous allez trouver toutes les
raisons du monde pour justifier votre n
de cette personne
vous allez chercher à appuyer votre
haine sur des raisons objectives sur des
raisons logiques et vous n'hésiterez pas
à construire des raisonnements
extrêmement sophistiqué qui vont vous
faire parvenir à la conclusion que cette
personne mérite votre détestation mais
ça c'est parce que vous aviez déjà
présupposés la conclusion à laquelle
vous vouliez arriver
la raison n'a eu qu'un rôle d'exécutant
elle n'a eu qu'un rôle d'outil pour
atteindre un objectif que vous aviez
fixé en amont pour que là encore la
raison intervient que de manière
secondaire
la raison intervient à posteriori mais
c'est ce qui était posée à priori qui a
guidé votre raisonnement vous vous êtes
contenter d'adapter votre raisonnement à
ce que vous vouliez au départ
et donc je disais que la raison à cette
fâcheuse tendance à vouloir
systématiquement contrarié ce que dit le
coeur c'est d'autant plus vrai que la
raison se nourrit de nos peurs la raison
se nourrit de nos angoisses
elle se nourrit de nos traumatismes et
ça c'est quelque chose que vous pouvez
constater auprès des personnes qui font
preuve d'une hyper prudence l'hyper
prudence par exemple de la maman envers
son enfant parce que cet enfant sera
peut-être tombé sur la tête lorsqu'il
était tout petit et que la maman ne
voudra pas revivre cette expérience
douloureuse
l'expérience aura laissé un traumatisme
qui fait que la raison va s'adapter à ce
traumatisme la raison va hypertrophié le
danger qui est à l'origine de cette
souffrance est donc à ce moment là la
raison ne remplit plus son rôle
d'auxiliaire elle ne remplit plus son
rôle d'agent de vérification et
d'anticipation
elle est mise au service de la peur elle
est mise au service d'une angoisse et
c'est ce qui fait qu'il est possible de
parler d'une raison sensible parce qu'on
a souvent la représentation de la raison
comme quelque chose d'hyper objectifs
comme quelque chose qui ne subit pas les
influences de nos affects
on a l'impression d'être capable d'avoir
un point de vue rationnel et objectif
sur les choses sans voir que nos
raisonnements sont toujours dirigés vers
un axe qui dépend de nos expériences
passées qui dépend de nos traumatismes
de nos inquiétudes et de nos angoisses
je parlais dans une précédente vidéo du
phénomène de l'aliénation l'aliénation
c'est précisément le fait de ne pas
pouvoir se rendre compte que l'on est
conditionnée c'est de ne pas pouvoir se
rendre compte que l'on est orienté dans
une certaine direction et qu'alors on
confère à notre raison un pouvoir
qu'elle n'a pas et dans ces cas là la
raison est mobilisé contre nos intérêts
elle est mobilisée contre ce à quoi nous
aspirons les vérités du coeur de pascal
sont là pour nous rappeler quelque chose
de fondamental c'est que ce qui est le
plus vrai et en même temps ce qui est le
plus au fond de nous
et ce qui est au fond nous est en même
temps ce qui est parfois le plus
difficile à entendre
parce que le coeur ne peut pas nous
parler plus fort qu il le fait déjà
parce qu'alors il ne serait plus dans
son rôle de conscience que l'on consulte
il deviendrait lui-même un tyran
hystérique et cela irait à l'encontre de
sa nature
lorsqu'on entend plus la voix du coeur
le problème ne vient peut-être pas du
coeur né de notre capacité à l'entendre
et pour l'entendre il est parfois
nécessaire de retirer ce qui le couvrent
de retirer le bruit qui nous empêche de
l'entendre
le bruit de notre mental le bruit de no
doubt le bruit de nos peurs car alors
vos peurs apparaîtront pour ce qu'elles
sont
des ombres
des ombres que l'on prend à tort pour
des objets réels des ondes retombe sont
que des fantômes sans pouvoir et qui
disparaîtront dès qu'on laissera entrer
un peu de lumière
je vous remercie
[Musique]